i also learned that you and i both have
something else in common i do love
cleaning
i am a compulsive cleaner when i am
yeah when i'm emotionally delicate
balance if i'm in a healthy mood
i can live with chaos if i am upset
about something i have to clean
i totally agree i remember that your
head is as messy as your room is with
something i heard once and i do think
that cleanliness is next to godliness
there is a spirituality there is an
order something you can control the end
result is so beautiful i i loved hearing
that you liked cleaning um now i want to
talk about your new show mr mayor
how is the show going and i have to ask
you also if you
like would you ever run for mayor in
real life
let's start with the simple
simple one
no
freaking way would i run for any office
ever no no i i have to take a vote to
cross the street so
no i'm not your guy
but the show i love the show this is
this is not a political show it's really
a workplace comedy but tina fey and
robert carlock have such an amazing
pedigree as writers that it was just
irresistible to me and then holly hunter
bobby moynihan kyla kennedy
mike heberwan and bella lavelle i mean
they are astounding
i mean really is like the a-list team
but that's what you had on cheers that's
what you had on good place you always
know how to surround yourself with such
extraordinary people and it just works
people love it yes yes and i and i have
to say i don't surround myself i i'm
lucky enough to pick amazing writers who
then
cast
so brilliantly um
i'm just you know i'm the last line on
cheers for my character was i'm the
luckiest son of a [ __ ] in the world
that was sam malone's last line on
cheers and that's definitely
a great phrase for my career you know i
am so blessed with good writing and very
creative people and actors and is it
true that also you have a unique bedtime
routine uh uh oh well yes and i know you
have photo proof bless mary's heart this
is a testimony to how much she loves me
um
yeah it started off with i uh injured my
neck
so i couldn't lie in bed and watch tv
because you know it would crank my neck
down and hurt and my hands would get
painful
so first i had to find these kind of
myths that you wear you know to sleep in
so that your hands are like this and
they don't hurt at night
and then i would love to watch tv in bed
with mary but i i couldn't then i
thought there must be a solution so
i went online and found these kind of
periscope glasses where you can lie flat
and still see there you are
what
i look like a ninja with uh with night
goggles on
that's what my wife goes to sleep
looking at
that's love my god i've never seen
anything like that you might have just
changed my life
i think i'm gonna go procure a pair of
those today
[Music]